bonsoir bonsoir
c'est ainsi que olivier et patrick
ollivier olivier d'accord alors on dit
que vous êtes pilote de ligne oui et ils
n'ont pas peur les passagers quand vous
dites le commandante de funès est
heureux de vous accueillir aborde non
non en général je un accueil assez
sympathique une fois il ya quand même
une dame qui a demandé si j'avais mon
permis de conduire mais quand même oui
alors je lui ai fait savoir qu'il me
restait deux points pour le vol et dont
vous vous êtes radiologue oui bien vous
êtes dans l'ailé les fils évidemment de
louis de funès et vous publiez louis de
funès ne parlait pas trop de moi les
enfants au cherche midi voilà alors
louis de funès est né en 1914 donc ça
veut dire qu'il aurait eu 90 ans
aujourd'hui 1 il est à courbevoie son
père était avocat et son père donc votre
grand-père avait fui l'espagne parce
qu'il voulait épouser une fille quoi et
les parents de la fille voulait pas
d'enquêté partie carrément de il l'a
bien là et ouais il l'a quand même
enlevé mais il paraissait assez courants
en espagne 1 une nuit elle était très
bourgeoise elle d'un très bon milieu les
parents voulaient pas en entendre parler
et ils ont passé la frontière c'est
comme ça qu'il s'est retrouvé en france
alors le père de louis de funès votre
grand-père donc ce mais en arrivant en
france il était avocat et donc il était
avocat quand ils arrivent en france il
se met dans les hameaux de synthétique
ça marche pas du tout parce qu'ils
étaient daltonien oui c'est un gag ça
aussi mais il distinguait pas le faire
du bruit après il part au venezuela
enfin c'est quelqu'un qui avait plutôt
pas très sérieux en fait votre grand
père dont je prends plus du titre très
méditerranéen il passait beaucoup
c'était un rêveur bon puis après il est
allé toujours pour les pierres au
venezuela parce que je crois qu'il ya
des mines d'émeraudes ouais bon bein il
n'en est certes pas très bien passée
mais il est parvenu oui oui et ma
grand-mère est allé le rechercher par la
peau des fesses au bout d'eux 24,5 en
parle à la ramener mais ferait mal à
terminer à malaga très très très mal
foutu mais recule alors ce qui est très
drôle c'est que louis de funès a
rencontré votre votre mère donc pendant
l'occupation il était pianiste de jazz
et un jury dans une boîte de jazz et
yann officiellement qui drague celle qui
devenu votre mère par la suite et lui
pour la protéger il a dit non je suis
son fiancé c'est extraordinaire alors là
il a bénéficié d'un passe droit c'est
qu'il était pianiste et les allemands
c'est très curieux vénérait les
musiciens où il a dit tiens c'est votre
fiancée il a abandonné tout de suite il
a passé beaucoup de barrages ces normes
se vend une scène de film quoi c'était à
t'imaginer louis de funès qui cela fait
l'humble indie
cher e rg pas courir le bruit avant
l'heure on retrouve exactement la même
c'est
aussi devenu vrai donc il est devenu
vraiment le le fiancé de huy après sur
le quai de métro voilà c'est
extraordinaire cette histoire non je vis
très belle histoire oui sont connus
d'une façon assez romanesque mais au
fond comme pas mal d'autres parisiens
qui attrapait les métros investir piqué
fusillé l'un meurt et alors ils étaient
déjà mariés en fait louis de funès avec
il est nommé germany d'état marina va
oublier la récente il s'en souvenait pas
à ce qu'il s'était marié 6,7 en avant
puisque tu tirer et bon puis toujours
pareil on a du mal à le croire mais
c'est la guerre et il dit à ma mère j'ai
débris d'un coup il a réalisé que
j'étais déjà marié alors ils se sont
rencontrés tous la main germaine a
trouvé ma mère très joli
ma mère a trouvé le futur mari de
germaine comme quoi les femmes ont
souvent les mêmes goûts fera son goût
aussi et du coup ils sont restés amis
tout là leur vie oui oui mais ils sont
restés amis l'ont toujours fait alors ce
qui est très bien aussi ce qui est très
film c'est que il n'avait pas de boulot
louis de funès au départ donc quand il
cherchait du travail comme ça il est
allé se balader l'après midi devant le
fouquet's où à l'époque avaient tous les
gens du cinéma qui étaient là évidemment
c'était le quartier général du cinéma
français dont il passait comme ça la vie
bras dessous mais alors ils ont le
marché quand il arrivait en bas il
remontait sa durée 4h 5h en espérant
rencontrer quelqu'un est quelquefois il
y avait un type qui sortait mme létard
en sept
ans on passait par hasard qu'un essai
elle arrive comme ça que dégoter des
petits rôles de bathia fait une journée
de marins avec une journée c'était de la
figuration il a ramé parce que c'est
l'époque où enfin beaucoup de beaucoup
de comédiens ont fait ça mais c'est
l'époque où il jouait au théâtre tous
ces gens là ensuite il avait 2 cabaret
dans la nuit un de cabaret jusqu'à 3
heures du matin prince le matin il
retournait tournée il a toujours eu peur
que ça salatin votre père je crois que
c'est un peu comme tous les gens qui ont
eu des débuts très difficiles bon il
était très conscient que c'était un
métier offert un risque qui disait si
j'me casse une jambe c'est cuit ce qui
est très drôle c'est qu'au départ donc
les réalisateurs les metteurs en scène
mettez louis de funès avec des grosses
bonnes femmes pour faire un effet un peu
du bout quoi pour faire quelque chose de
comique et votre mère ne lui plaisait
pas du tout et c'est votre mère qui a
choisi claude gensac pour eux le comique
c'est un ovni croupier on amène à une
grosse vendeuse et rigoler et l après
c'est au théâtre et pour les gendarmes
qu'elle a choisi claude gensac mais
avons quand même quand il nya qu il a
joué en tournée oscars il a eu une maria
pacôme way et c'était formidable alors
en fait votre père quand il a connu
votre mère elle avait d'un peu plus
d'argent elle avait été levée dans un
château etc quand il a eu de l'argent
lui lui a acheté un appartement au parc
monceau pour lui qu'il a voulu lui
recréer le cadre de vie de ses enfants
n'avait vécu dans un hôtel particulier
du parc monceau il a acheté un
appartement dans le parc on sera là pour
qu elle l a même vu carey il était quand
ils ont eu ces périodes très difficiles
elle a quand même tout abandonner pour
lui alors il lui avait dit je te
recréerait tout ce que tu as perdu gris
la fin c'est un destin extraordinaire un
privé bien sûr alors qu'aujourd'hui on
sait qu'à un moment elle elle hérite du
château donc lui aussi et alors là mais
comme tous les anciens pauvres c'est à
dire qu'il a peur des cambriolages dans
ce château il passe son temps à se
balader avec un trousseau de 30 clé
parce qu'ils voient là une fille
complètement en quoi comme les gens qui
ont pas été habitués étant jeune sans
doute à y faire mais c'est tout ses
portes les secrétaires clé de caves clé
de la porte de la chapelle tous a été
fermée tous les jours à la même heure ça
prenait une heure et demie pour fermer
toutes les portes et on l'attendait nous
à table on attendait qui viennent pour
dîner april a l'air vérifier ça
reprenait un quart d'heure
et en vérité l'un derrière ce qui est
incroyable c'est que qui était
fanatiques des clés des serrures des
cadenas et des alarmes le jour de ses
obsèques l'alarmé s'est déclenchée le
convoi quittait on entendu mais à
l'armurerie je ne sais pas à ces
maillots riz sans bruit avec un coup
heureux que tu aies un tabouret c'était
fermé près de du truc d'alcool ouais
alors avec les autres acteurs c'est très
intéressant ce que vous racontez il est
peu d'atomes crochus avec gaba parce
qu'en fait un jour il avait demandé à
gabin s'il avait vu ses films et l'autre
avaient dit non j'en ai vu aucun j'avais
beaucoup vexé en fait c'était pas très
bien élevés c'est une danse étaient sur
le même plateau le journaliste qui passe
vous avez vu il passe d'abord voir mon
père vous aimez les films de gabin pas
forcément je les aime tous ils étaient 1
femme et moi aussi d'ailleurs et il
passe la loge d'après en longeant les
eaux que rien
n'est pas très fin ouais alors été potec
beauville ah oui oui oui très et ennemi
de jean marais mais il disait janot tu
donnes glynn waiting match tu donnes en
fait il avait une réputation d'emmerdeur
parce qu'il était très créatif et sur
les tournages il voulait absolument
participer à la réalisation 1,7 à gries
vérifier tout dans le cinéma français
c'était quand même assez catastrophique
je crois est évidemment les gens qui
travaillent man disent que vous êtes un
emmerdeur ouais ouais et les gens qui
travaillent bien disent que vous êtes
parfait toujours la même histoire
partout alors il avait du mal à sortir
parce que évidemment tout le monde lui
disait allez faites mois de ça fait
moins ça alors il faisait une petite
grimace on va quand même c'est normal
c'est au bout d'un moment ça le fatigue
et donc quand il sortait il avait un
passe-montagne des lunettes noires est
extraordinaire à voir non disputent un
passe montagne pour pas être reconnus on
reconnaissait encore plus atteint ce
niveau ça qui est terrible et y avait
des gens quand même qui est qui était
inquiète et qui avait un totalement
serais je me souviens dans un avion il
ya un monsieur qui s'est installé à côté
de lui la laine nantes à paris et qui
devait mettre à côté de vous comme ça
vous allez me faire des grimaces pendant
le vol ça va faire face et le voyage
est alors il était tellement renfermé
chez lui qu'il sortait plus dans l'est
dans l'est magasins et un jour il voit à
la télé ils voient des caddies à la télé
edit c'est quoi ce truc heures les
dimanches les petits chariots qu'on a
dans les supermarchés maintenant il sait
même pas que ça existait et c'est là où
ma mère s'est dit il ya quand même
quelque chose qui va pas il va plus là
il est trop
ça un skull ouais alors ce qu'on apprend
dans votre bouquin qu'il avait un projet
que polanski oui oui là il a rencontré
pendant ce qu'il admirait beaucoup il
avait beaucoup aimé le bal des vampires
raies étudiées et polanski mais aussi
ceux rencontrés ils ont déjeuné ensemble
dans un restaurant parisien et
il avait un projet puis les affaires ont
éloigné polanski
de france et du scénario ça s'est jamais
fait mais c'est dommage il rêve c'est
avec ce rôle
était drôle alors aujourd'hui qui sont
les successeurs de votre père pour vous
christian clavier la contrefaçon
anophèles arrêté en douane suis là c'est
pas normal qu'on saisisse des sacs
vuitton est une contrefaçon harkat pur
abbaoui moi je serai les douaniers jeu
il passerait plus à vous trouvez que
c'est la contrefaçon de la contrefaçon
ne sait même pas de limitation c'est de
la contrefaçon et de la récupération
alors là je suis très nette bon il ya
des gens qui sont inspirés il ya
d'autres gens mais là non je suis très
remonté
mais depuis quand depuis toujours ou un
autre depuis qu'il s'est mis à limiter
avance est un excellent acteur magie
harry dans le père noël est une ordure
c'est après quand j'ai commencé avant le
plat j'ai alors regardé limites michaël
youn me trouvais que il a quelque chose
de
sérieux je pense que si mon père voyait
tous les nouveaux acteurs
il leur père ray énormément il dirait
surtout qu'ils ont un très bon
tempérament et mais qui sont pas du tout
sont pas des joues pas dans le même
genre je veux dire mais de son style à
lui je pense qu'il n'y en a pas appuyé a
pas de raison qu'il y en ait non mais là
josé garcia qui est formidable et garcia
et lycée elie semoun qui est
sensationnel et à peu près la même vue
d'ailleurs dès demain métier que lui
quand il quand il dit que quand il dit
qu'il joue des personnages qui n'est
même qui n'aimerait pas être c'est tout
à fait ce que pensait le
grand bain
il a dit quel tempérament
c'est sûr il avait adoubé coluche il
avait accepté
il n'avait pas les rapports de rivalité
très bien entendu rien entendu en plus
chez coluche on mangeait bien c'était
tout pour plaire à mon père il allait
manger chez lui tout le monde les amis
faisaient la cuisine ils étaient ils
étaient ravis
josh midi
alors quand il a fait rabbi jacob vote
clair il a dit ce film m'a lavé l'esprit
ça veut dire quoi ça oui tout le monde a
au moins ils étaient ils étaient francs
parce qu'au fond peut-être que dans
rabbi jacob il a découvert un monde qui
ne connaissait à 102 voilà il parlait
souvent de se laver l'âme parce que ils
considéraient qu'ils avaient tous les
défauts du monde tous les défauts de la
terre et qu'il fallait faire absolument
une introspection pour 0 la l'info faut
vider tout ça il était toujours très
inquiet j'ai toujours un peu de jalousie
des choses comme ça il a bien des
défauts quand même ce louis de funès par
huit ans il était casse-pieds d'abord à
ces cas spinetta view brûlons les idoles
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qui n'était pas marrant
c'est louis de funès
mais ce genre de gens ne sont pas
toujours amusant à vivre tous les jours
sont quand même des anxieux
moyenne poursuivre et au téléphone qui
avait pas de téléphone portable alors il
s'inquiète elle téléphone ça n'est pas
non non elle était un peu casse bonbons
ouais ouais carrément qu'est-ce qu'ils
aient jamais fait rire chez lui vraiment
un truc le pire truc c'est quand il
militait
il vous imitez emporte tout le temps oui
on réveille que j'étais toujours de
mauvaise humeur que j'avais la langue
qui prenait jusque là parce que j'étais
mauvaises langues en faut plus
qu'est-ce qu'il a complètement raté
votre père dans sa vie ne pas vivre plus
longtemps - dans le stress éléments à
quel âge 69 ans
quel film il aurait mieux fait de pas
faire
abandonner en tout 60 donc les films
alimentaires qui se fait pendant les
années 50 où plein oui il fallait bien
qu'on fait c'est sur un arbre perché
c'était pas terrible ça m'était d'or
quel secret vous a toujours caché après
après sa mort mais qui avait d'aider des
bouteilles de très bon bourgogne dans la
caf l'année c'est absolument pas ce
qu'il en commencé tous les angles volet
buvait jamais il commandait pour faire
plaisir aux négociants en fait oui ils
disent ne faut pas je le déçois chaque
année commander les caisses mais ils
étaient onze à oui il ya un truc est
génial dans le bouquin c'est quand il
aller dans les restaurants ils se
croyaient obligés de commander parce
qu'il se disait comme les gens savent
que j'ai du pognon si je commande pas
ses affaires un peu mesquin il était
comme ça c'est comme ça qu'ils m'ont
commandé aux négociants de pinard a
séparé les mêmes histoires et des rentes
on a découvert des rentes ouais ouais
les roms qui versait à deschamps c'était
des sommes folles étaient tous les mois
alors y en a qu'on connaissait mais on a
d'autres qu'on ne connaissait pas comme
ça comme ça mais disons qu'il n'avait
pas tellement plus connu la veuve d'un
metteur en scène qu'il n'avait jamais
fait tourner ce qui n'a jamais compris
dans la vie c'est quoi qu'il fallait
être plus homme d'affaires cède jamais
compris ah non mais vous savez qu'un
jour christian fechner lui a proposé de
deux non plus d'avoir un cachet une
participation au pourcentage ce qui
était beaucoup plus intéressant ce qui
les entrées des garanties au début il a
dit oui pas d'accord oui je vais le
faire puisque tu le dis et puis dix
jours après il l'a rappelé un matin il
lui a dit mais christian vous m'aimez
bien on s'entend bien oui bien sur wii
écoutez on va arrêter ce contrat là je
reprends le cachet parce que sinon à
s'engueuler
ce soir mais pas
parodie
cette aux éditions du cherche midi et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu